you've been in the news quite a bit
lately not by choice basically the
number two in this Fortune 500 company
was running these different identities
uh to attack me attack my dead
grandfather attack my family members
what about the Twitter files I think
it's a big problem that's why I really
want Elon to stay selfishly as a CEO is
because I think he has the brain power
to solve how we get Twitter to be
decentralized the last time we talked I
think was towards the beginning of 2022
and you rightfully said hey I think
bitcoin's gonna crash I mean it's crazy
to think that you've had all this this
increase in interest rates and it's
still saying that what fifteen sixteen
thousand dollars all right when you
think of your portfolio today given
where we are in the economy how are you
allocating Capital just don't buy any of
the [ __ ] that doesn't make money
all right guys bang bang I've got bill
here uh you and I dungeon for a long
time now there's a whole bunch of stuff
we're going to talk about from Elon and
Twitter which is the deal you invested
in Bitcoin the economy the housing
market all that but first you've been in
the news quite a bit lately uh there is
a 15 billion not by choice necessarily
okay there's a 15 billion dollar
publicly traded company of which your
grandfather started called polti homes
sure and uh one of the executives there
was essentially running like a bot farm
and coming after you allegedly and we
have obviously very good proof uh we
feel very confident in it but uh
basically the number two in this Fortune
500 company was running these different
identities uh to attack me attack my
dead grandfather attack my family
members and in many cases it was almost
daily uh that this was going on you know
I get a lot of stuff that said bad about
me just like you do on Twitter okay I
can handle a lot but when you have in
this case a guy taking a dead guy's
identity and repurposing it for these
Twitter Bots for example and then having
these AI generated photos there's one
girl she looks like in her 20s or 30s
another guy looks in his 20s or 30s and
then you got this dead guy right and
they're all you know attacking and
amplifying each other and what's really
interesting about it is that we saw a
lot lot of non-public confidential
information coming from these different
accounts these fictitious accounts and
so you know me being a former director
of the company you know I was able to
pick up on a little bit of okay you know
that's not information that's out there
in the public domain this is potentially
a problem and so I started to get smart
with it and without getting into the
forensics too much we uncovered it and
like you said it's become quite a big
story in the last week or so so this
individual was doing this and um as you
started to uncover it like did you think
that oh there's a bot Farm or was it
more of uh that accounts weird let me go
check that account out and then like you
kind of uncovered the whole thing well
what was weird was that they were
starting to interact with each other so
for instance when I'm I'm uh improvising
I'm not necessarily quoting a tweet here
because I'm in litigation with the guy
I'm going after him personally for doing
this I'm not suing the company but
um you know they would interact with
each other so some some one of the Bots
would say something and then the other
bot would come in and say say something
back to give this impression of you know
that they were talking to each other and
then they would like the tweets and
retweet them and stuff like that and
again you know my concern is I uh care a
lot about my grandfather my family's
former business polti homes uh I care a
lot about our name brand a lot about uh
the company being successful and if you
have a number two this guy was the
incoming CEO of this Fortune 500 company
running this type of smear campaign uh
this is not somebody that you want
running a 15 billion dollar a year
Revenue company I mean how does somebody
like this have time to do something like
this when they're responsible for so
much across this Fortune 500 company it
just doesn't make sense how common is
this type of stuff inside of these big
companies I think a lot of people
throughout the last couple of years have
seen various large companies that are
publicly traded that you think uh it's
just a normal company I'll put that in
air quotes right but then you come to
realize that either the individuals are
doing crazy things or the company's
doing crazy things like you've been in
and around these companies you're on the
Board of this specific company
how common is this type of stuff well
you know always at the board level
you're always wondering okay what isn't
management telling us right they're
always telling you great things that
they're doing but what aren't they
telling you I think you know and I I
don't know what the board's thinking
necessarily but I what I would speculate
whether it's this board or another board
or a company board is that when you see
this kind of stuff you start to say okay
how did this guy have this much time to
do this kind of stuff on company time
allegedly we have very good proof and
potentially on company devices and
Company equipment I mean this is a
problem and so you know it begs the
question okay what is going on in some
of these other Fortune 500 companies how
do we make sure that you know as we have
Pension funds investors people investing
in these big companies you know it's one
thing to invest in a crypto company no
offense and you know you know that
you're getting a risky deal it's another
thing to invest in a Fortune 500 company
and have an executive be running
something like this and I think that's
what's so shocking about this or like
the CEO race recently who I think it was
beyond meets guy right who bit
somebody's ear at a football game I mean
it's just behavior that shouldn't be
happening for a Fortune 500 executive
why has the media been so interested in
this you've been on a bunch of different
uh outlets and and they seem to really
have kind of latched on to this what is
it is it that it is a Fortune 500
company is it that it's an executive is
it that you it's your guys uh family's
company and your name still on it even
though I don't know if you guys own
shares or not still um like why is the
media so kind of enthralled with this
specific story well they first thought
it was just wild accusations they said
polti and I was even on CNBC and Scott
Wapner saying these are wild allegations
you know and I understand he's a
journalist he's got to push back but all
those wild allegations looks like
they're pretty darn true and you know
polti group went I was on CNBC on
Thursday at 4 30 or something and by
Friday morning the gentleman was fired
from polti group so uh there's something
true here we're going to get to the
bottom of it but I think that people
just have a hard time believing that
some somebody in this position could be
doing this kind of stuff yeah and it
begs the question of Twitter more in
general right I've seen studies where
people have looked at negative content
around a specific story and it's like 80
85 percent comes from a certain number
of accounts right we've seen uh
accusations of Twitter like hate speech
and all that stuff skyrocketing since
Elon took over Elon pushes back and says
No actually that's down we've been able
to to kind of mitigate those risks how
do you think of Twitter as a product
itself in terms of the conversation
where if this does happen like is that a
prevalent thing on Twitter or is that
just some person who ends up doing this
in this one specific case and it's not
actually the norm on Twitter yeah I
don't think it's necessarily the norm I
mean this was very calculated very
malicious right I get trolls all the
time all day every day right that same
if you're on Twitter that's basically
what you do for a living is you hear
from people
um but you very rarely see a
well-compensated Fortune 500 executive
use that brain power to conceal his
identity and discuss the company by
which he is a senior executive of I mean
this is very unheard of as far as I'm
concerned I mean you know when you go to
sell stock or when you go to discuss
stock as far as I know and obviously
we're getting into the all the
legalities of this but when you go to
discuss a public security that you're
affiliated with and you're a senior
executive with information that the
public is not aware of you cannot be
using that position to you know put out
information as long as you're not you
know disclosing that to all investors
and investor relations departments I
mean that's why they have investor
relations departments and what was the
type of non-public information obviously
don't say the the information but like
what was it was it like Revenue type
metrics was it other things well just
some of the stuff that we've released so
far is about employees and layoffs in
particular and and some of the
information that only somebody who was
kind of on the inside necessarily would
know and that tips you guys off to some
degree it tipped me off as a former
director of the company saying okay this
is stuff that only somebody uh with
access to board materials or to CEO
would know and that raises another
question you know how did this guy get
this information right because uh you
know he wouldn't necessarily have had
access when I was on the board to
certain information so there's a lot to
unpack here and we'll see but uh you
know I'm just glad that we at least put
a stop to it temporarily at a minimum I
mean this has been going on for years we
think
one of the weird things or maybe unusual
things is that like your family started
a business the name polti is on the
business but you all aren't there
operating the business is that like a
weird thing do you think that uh many
families deal with that when they start
companies they end up either bringing
them public and they no longer operate
them like how do you kind of balance
that in your head that like your
family's name is on something but you
guys aren't actually making the
decisions well my grandfather started at
age 18 he was a carpenter and he built
it into something that was way more
successful than he ever thought and I
think the reason he went public was he
wanted to incentivize the employees to
build something amazing so I think from
an early age kind of the DNA of the
company was maybe more and it's hard to
believe this these days but I think they
do exist especially for a Depression era
boy like my grandfather where they're
very selfless and so you know they were
very much like hey let's get everybody
Rich who's helping us get rich Let's
have everybody do it that way so you
know it's never really been about oh
just it's polti on the door and
everything but we do feel a commitment
to make sure that you know we stand
behind it one of the things that he
allegedly did was he was attacking
people for not being able to qualify for
a polti home not not being able to
purchase a polti home necessarily and
that's also what we want to make sure
that you know Executives aren't making
fun of people for their financial status
yeah uh we mentioned Twitter earlier uh
you were an investor in the take private
of Twitter yes with Elon kind of leading
the way but he raised money uh privately
how can you explain to people kind of
the private fundraising process or at
least your experience in it in terms of
uh the 44 billion dollar price point
obviously was this big number and I
think there's a lot of people who think
like Elon pulled 44 billion dollars like
he just withdrew it from his bank
account one day and like sent it
somewhere
um talk a little bit just this like how
that type of deal comes together well it
was really interesting because I've
invested in a lot of different funds and
stuff and usually you're waiting for the
fun and you're waiting for these
different things and what was kind of
cool about it was in real time you were
watching him and obviously I didn't have
any information about this but you know
from the news reports you're reading
about how he was selling stock to
basically fund the purchase and so it
was almost like okay you're kind of you
know riding alongside or behind Elon so
to speak as he's going to do this and so
it was very very much backseat but my my
general investment thesis was that
um you know and I've been exposed to a
lot of entrepreneurs whether it's my
grandfather or other people and I've
been able to learn from a lot of these
type of people as I know you have and
you know Elon is just the world's
greatest entrepreneur as far as I'm
concerned and so you know I'm not
necessarily sure what he's going to do
with Twitter but I certainly would have
been wouldn't bet against him and so I
put you know several million dollars
into the deal and we'll see what happens
it's fascinating to hear your thought
process because I think a lot of people
would assume that investors are going
and they're looking through all the
documents and the financials and and all
the stuff and sometimes like that's not
even provided to the level of detail
that uh an individual would believe it
to be but also we saw a number of
well-known investors I think Mark
Andreessen uh some of the texts came out
where he basically had said hey we're in
for I think it was 250 million dollars
or something we don't need to do any
diligence like we're just in and that
was kind of the theme of the whole deal
which was fascinating but that like
leads me to believe that most investors
are just saying this guy was at least
integral if not the driver of SpaceX and
Tesla and boring company neural like all
these other companies that appear to be
working
I bet that he can figure Twitter out
yeah I'm gonna bet on him more so than
I'm going to bet on this specific
Financial State of the deal or anything
like that and he has such confidence
with it right he knew the platform right
we're power users of it most to your
audience is power users of it so here he
is a guy going in to acquire a company
he knows it very well back and forth
right he's a brilliant engineer he's a
brilliant uh software engineer as well
uh he's going to figure it out and I
think he will so what do you think this
thing that they're doing with the tweets
by the way where they're going to put
the view count on the tweets I think
that is going to be explosive because I
don't think people understand how far a
lot of these tweets go even you know it
doesn't matter whether you have 10
followers 100 followers or three million
followers you know these tweets get seen
by a lot of people and I think once you
start to see how many people are seeing
these tweets the thing is just going to
even spread more like a virus you and I
both uh because we talked about in the
past have done hundreds of millions of
Impressions per month on that platform
and there's almost no other platform in
the world where you can do that on a
consistent basis right it is in my
opinion the most powerful social media
platform uh when used correctly which I
think you know you and I both have
figured out to some degree
um what else do you think he should do
so he has the view count public so
people can see hey here's how much reach
these tweets are getting are there other
things that stick out in your mind he's
got to figure out how to monetize it you
know I've been one of the early people
who give away cash on Twitter it was
kind of a thing that was once upon a
time like what is this what is this all
about now it's like the hot thing to do
um and so if you can figure out how to
tap into this you know strike while the
iron's hot on this money thing on
Twitter I'm not necessarily saying it
has to be philanthropy but I know
obviously he has a background and David
Sachs has a background in PayPal and
these things but if they can figure out
how to make this a Commerce site and
really a what is it a WeChat so to speak
this thing could be otherworldly in
terms of powerful I mean this could be
the most powerful app in my opinion in
human history yeah what's fascinating to
me is that uh it already serves the
purpose that LinkedIn was supposed to
serve like I don't check LinkedIn for
messages or like networking or any of
that type of stuff uh but if somebody
DMS me on Twitter for the most part I
see it right
um and then if I want to reach out to
someone uh maybe I'm weird but I go to
Twitter first I don't go to Instagram I
don't go to LinkedIn and go to Facebook
I don't look for their email I just like
go to Twitter am I following them are
they following me can I DM them and but
that's also the industry that you're in
right correct absolutely I'm in the
construction industry for example and
you wouldn't necessarily go find a
foreman or something like that on there
for sure but I think that he understands
the tech industry and the finance
Industries on Twitter and so like if
you're in those Industries it works yeah
in media and so that's like a networking
thing but what you're really talking
about is if he can then cross over and
also make it a payments thing now rather
than me go to dinner with a friend and I
venmo or I PayPal or I do any of these
other things I just go on Twitter and
I'm able to just pay someone that's
pretty damn powerful because if you can
get payments on there plus you have the
uh communication and you've got the
networking you start to rival every
single other app to be genius and not
only that but you know again because
we're Twitter philanthropy think about
it from this standpoint we go out there
every day we raise money for people who
are dying of cancer who need groceries
who need medicine who need all these
kind of things and you know it's called
direct giving so it's not this
traditional philanthropy which can be
great where you give 30 million dollars
to build some building okay this is
direct giving this is acute right to the
source right to the issue whether it's
groceries or what have you let's say you
see people on Twitter for example and
you see somebody who's dying of cancer
by the way this happens every day okay I
see it every day
um and you want to help that person you
could click a button boom send them cash
now right now you have to go to their
profile and then you have to choose
between Bitcoin and USD so you know if
Elon can figure out how to crack that
code I actually think that it can do
tremendous wonders and this is going to
sound like a little bit of a crazy idea
but it can do tremendous wonders in ways
that the government and Social Security
and Medicaid won't be able to do and
it'll get the money quicker faster
directly to people I've always thought
uh and not in my idea yeah just won that
version of time the velocity leads to
productivity right so if you can get
velocity of money if you can get
velocity of output if you can get
velocity of communication you get output
what you're really talking about here is
if you can get velocity or reduced
friction in the movement of money back
and forth people will not only use it
for traditional like peer-to-peer type
payments or reimbursing each other or
whatever but they'll find these new use
cases which I think one you pioneered
was this Twitter philanthropy and
there's probably plenty others that
someone out there in the world will
either figure out the Pioneer they'll
champion and all Elon has to do is just
reduce the friction of being able to
allow people to pay each other and then
just let the internet magic go to work
correct and I don't know if you saw what
he did but he renamed it from Super
followers to subscribers that was genius
um just because super followers sounds
just very Tacky in my opinion and now
that he has subscribers he can compete
with sub stack he can be more like
YouTube so we'll see it is a little
concerning uh that he wants to step down
and see a CEO I think it's just because
he's fatigued but again I don't know any
thing there but yeah that would be
disappointing would you be disappointed
yeah yeah I mean I think that he's going
to make it work no matter what I think
he's always going to be you know
actually the CEO but he you know nobody
can replace his genius yeah what about
the Twitter files like in this whole
like dump of uh data and information and
ideas like there's the information and
then also how he's publicizing it like
he went to Independent journalists and
said like hey I'm going to give it to
you rather than give it to one of the
big media companies what did you think
about that I thought it was excellent
and in fact I just started polti files
this last week to expose these different
Bots that were you know using dead
people's identities to attack me and my
family and stuff like that and so I'm
leaking this stuff out you know slowly
but surely and it's called the polti
file so I was very impressed with the
Twitter files and we should be doing
more of that right at one point you had
Wikileaks and you know now it's the
Twitter files and uh the more
transparency the better yeah uh and then
what about the actual information itself
where there was uh social media
companies working with the government
was providing information like how do
you think about uh is it there should be
no communication between the platforms
and the government there should be a lot
there should be somewhere in between
like how do you just think about as a
society like what should be acceptable
and what shouldn't be I think it's a big
problem and I think Jack Dorsey was
trying to figure it out in terms of
being decentralized I think that's why
we love Bitcoin right it's because it's
not controlled by any one person so
that's why I really want Elon to stay
selfishly as a CEO is because I think he
has the brain power to solve how we get
Twitter to be decentralized uh to where
really unless it's something where
you're breaking the law or whatever you
know somebody who just wakes up on the
wrong side of the bed one morning can't
shut you off at Twitter yeah I mean that
that should be Twitter should almost be
a human right in some to some extent in
my opinion why do you think it should be
a human race because I think that you
know everybody has the right to free
speech in my opinion and again you know
as long as you're not actually causing
harm or doing some some form of
illegality
um you know uh you know and again scams
and these type of things should all be
taken off there but
um you know I think that people need to
express themselves and when you don't
express themselves then what happens is
you get things like January 6 or you get
other different things where people get
bottled up and then they they're going
to find a way to you know do what
they're gonna do one way so you might as
well have it in the open yeah I think
sunlight is the best disinfectant yeah I
agree with that uh you mentioned Bitcoin
the last time we talked I think was
towards the beginning of 2022 uh and you
rightfully said hey I think bitcoin's
gonna crash uh you were smart enough not
to put an exact uh price Target or a
timeline on it but you're like sometime
this year I think it would be like a
correction uh talk a little bit now in
hindsight after having said that uh kind
of this year and how it's transpired how
much of it fit within what you thought
was going to happen versus you got the
intended outcome but maybe some of the
details were different good question so
you know in in the economy obviously the
way that I look at it anyway is that
housing and transportation can often be
leading indicators of the economy and so
what I was seeing when I was here with
you last earlier this year was I was
seeing some of the deterioration and
housing right because it's a leading
indicator and so then what you saw also
from my perspective was you saw a
deterioration in lumber pricing and so
you started to see some of these
Commodities that had gotten so big so
fast you know in terms of price and so I
said it's only a matter of time before
you know the drain and liquidity coupled
with this commodity disinflation uh
affects Bitcoin and so that's why I had
said that what are your thoughts about
Bitcoin now price has gone down 75 I
think you're still holding Bitcoin you
like Bitcoin is that all true yes and
I'm going to wait to be buying a little
bit more I think that uh it's still a
little too expensive given liquidity
Dynamic I think we're going to have
continued liquidity problems in the
market in my opinion uh first quarter
next year and is that all being driven
by the FED just tightening Financial
conditions keep raising interest rates
and selling off assets you know again
you're talking to a housing guy so I
have kind of a unique perspective from
an interest rate standpoint we say in
housing that in interest rates of the
mother's milk of Housing and so when you
cut off the mother's milk of housing in
my opinion that also goes Downstream
into the economy and so I think that
these interest rates the effects of
these interest rates has not really been
felt it's been felt in housing but I
don't think it's made itself to
mainstream business and as you think
about those interest rates we've seen
all year long they've continued to
increase we've seen the sell-off of
asset prices and they've stated we want
to destroy demand we want to destroy
demand they've done a fantastic job on
the investment appetite side there is
very little appetite for investment at
the moment
on the other side though you have
consumer spending you have a household
income you have savings like all these
other metrics that seem to still be like
fairly healthy how do you balance uh
destruction of investment assets and
investment prices with what still seems
to be a somewhat strong consumer I think
it's only a matter of time and I think
you know we're in the HVAC business
that's where I spend a lot of my time
direct to the homeowner and we are
seeing people being really uh reticent
so to speak to spend the big ticket
items that they were doing a year or two
ago so I think it's going to be a lag
effect and it's just a matter of time
yeah and that means that the FED at some
point will have to Pivot and I think
they already have I mean they went down
to 50 basis points and
um you know I think they'll continue to
increase but it could be potentially
pretty tough four and a half percent now
what do you think they get to don't know
but I'll tell you six I don't know but
I'll tell you this these mortgage rates
are not very good I mean these are not
these are not very good things for the
housing market and so I think it's going
to be good for the housing market as a
buyer as a consumer I think it's going
to help a lot of people people but
the zoning in our country has made it in
my opinion to where in addition to
people not being able to build enough
because of the last recession people
don't want to build a lot of these big
subdivisions anymore and so I think
that's also going to keep housing prices
pretty high
when you evaluate the mortgage market
we've seen an explosion I know people
who are getting you know 2.2 2.5 percent
mortgages a year ago uh now all of a
sudden they're looking at five or six
percent is it literally just number goes
up demand goes down or is there more
complexity to it no it's literally as
simple as that I mean obviously you have
the wage issue as well but you have you
have basically if you dumb it down you
have interest rates and you have wages
and wages have stayed pretty strong
whether that's through inflation or
through you know the inertia in the
economy but you have this interest rate
situation and it definitely what it does
is it initially affects traffic and then
once you see it in traffic you see it in
orders and then once you see it in order
so you start seeing it in cancellations
of homes and you've seen cancellations
go from you know in some of these cases
12 13 of orders to 25 percent of orders
I mean that's a huge increase yeah in in
cancellations people you know signing a
purchase agreement and then canceling it
later that's not good you know a quarter
of the homes being cancel yeah when you
see something like inflation coming down
on an a year-over-year basis so now
we're down around seven percent or so it
was up almost nine percent
um is that something where you're just
like okay if that number keeps coming
down then the FED uh will kind of uh go
sideways they don't need to keep raising
interest rates or do you start looking
at the compounding effect right I think
last year in November of 2021 year over
year inflation was six point eight
percent uh this year is like 7.1 7.2
percent so now we're getting into a
period where more than six percent
inflation compound annual growth rate
which is a really scary number for the
average consumer like how do you start
to incorporate that into your investment
decisions or even your consumption well
I think this is why you and I both love
Bitcoin right and so much your audience
loves Bitcoin is because we understand
the power of compounding so even though
in rate of change terms you're not going
to have the increases that you saw this
year in inflation right it's still going
to remain elevated and you know
especially again I'm a housing guy so
you know if you keep these housing
prices high for a long period of time
and you know you're essentially
devaluing the dollar through every year
compounded right these mortgages are
also going to be devalued because
they're based in U.S dollars right so I
think you're absolutely correct that
this is why Bitcoin is so attractive
over the Long Haul
um I just happen to think that it might
have some more downside before it I mean
it could potentially scream again right
and just epic fashion yeah I mean it's
pretty crazy the whole use case that you
laid out when everybody thought you were
crazy a few years ago has totally proven
itself as far as I'm concerned the two
pieces to the argument the store value
uh there's lots of people who say hey if
it's a store value then you also said it
was going to be an inflation hedge and
uh they look at the price it has been in
many ways though compared to other
things so that's my argument is Bitcoin
has actually been the best inflation
hedge because uh if you go back to 2020
it was trading eight thousand dollars uh
before inflation crossed over five
percent it went from 8 000 all the way
up to sixty four thousand dollars in
March of 2020 uh one and so from that
standpoint assets and markets are
forward-looking it saw inflation is
coming people ran to an inflation hedge
asset and it increased in price now
what's happening is as the FED said hey
we're going to tighten conditions we're
going to go ahead and Destroy demand
again forward-looking all of the people
who are holding and say oh these
inflation hedge assets aren't going to
do nearly as well as they bring down
inflation they have liquidity uh issues
in the economy I'm going to sell this
asset I'm going to go into value stocks
or other types of uh cash or whatever
that's to me exactly how an inflation
head should be working is it goes up
before the inflation hits and then it
comes down own when they go and they
destroy Demand right exactly right
mic drop here and say it better yeah
when you think of your portfolio today
that's just math I mean anybody who
takes issue with that look at where
Bitcoin was and look at where it's at
now I mean it's crazy to think that
you've had all this this increase in
interest rates and it's still staying at
what fifteen sixteen thousand dollars
it's double where it was at the
beginning of 2020 you know I mean pigs
get fat Hogs get slaughtered so anybody
who's claiming oh well you know it went
up really high well you know should it
have really gone up that high was that
part of the Mania as well I don't think
that it has fundamentally something to
do with Bitcoin yeah and when you think
of those fundamentals everything still
you think is intact in terms of like the
argument for Bitcoin it's just the price
has the volatility to it yes yes all
right when you think of your portfolio
today given where we are in the economy
how are you allocating Capital like do
you think of percentages to stocks or
real estate or Bitcoin or how do you
think about it yeah this episode is
brought to you by eight sleep good sleep
is a game changer and the eight sleep
pod is the best sleep machine I sleep on
it every single night a great night of
sleep allows you to be healthier be more
arrested and have more energy throughout
the day and on the brand new eight sleep
pod 3 you can sleep as cold as 55
degrees Fahrenheit or as hot as 110
degrees Fahrenheit that's the secret of
thermoregulation better sleep better
energy get yourself in each sleep you
can go to eatsleep.com pump today to go
ahead and get 150 off your order
eatsleep.com pump not only do I sleep on
it every night it literally changed my
life and I begged the founders to let me
invest in the company hsleep.com go get
yourself an eight sleep pod and get a
better night of sleep almost 100 in
stocks and other than my Bitcoin
allocation and the way that I look at it
is is I also sell calls on my stock so
you know for people who aren't familiar
with that you know you can have a broker
you can have somebody else you know
effectively sell calls and especially in
a liquidity draining environment there
are opportunities where if you're smart
you can just you know let the time
premium bleed off and then basically
pocket the difference so I've done
fairly well with that strategy now now
when the economy is doing well and when
there's plenty of liquidity you can get
your head ripped off selling calls but
so far it's worked out pretty well for
me and then I'm investing in these other
construction type businesses when I say
construction it's really Home Services
businesses so heating and air
conditioning and stuff like that you
know air conditioning is kind of like
oxygen everybody needs it and so I'm
pretty passionate about you know selling
air conditioning and um you know making
sure that people have it we have a big
business in Phoenix Arizona for example
and people need air conditioning in
Phoenix what is the logic outside of
just air conditioning so Home Services
in general is it just these are
businesses that are are needed and if
you operate them well they're profitable
basically okay yeah I've got a friend
who I've talked about on the bike we
like simple yeah how simple is good
um he started to buy up a lot of
electrical companies right with
electricians and his thesis was
basically hey we're not producing nearly
as many electricians as we used to trade
school wasn't as popular people still
need electrical work done it's not going
to be automated away if I go and I buy
up these companies who are usually
family run and you know there's some
sort of transition period between
Generations uh at some point I just have
a monopoly a pricing Monopoly on markets
and so I can increase prices I can do
the things I need to do because I have
the electricians and there aren't that
many competitors is that true in other
types of Home Services well I wish I
would have talked to your friend and I
don't know is he making money doing it
or not I believe so okay good so it
depends you know what kind of um maybe
he's looking for investors depends what
kind of electrician work you're doing uh
one of the problems from my perspective
with electrician and plumbing as a
business is yes it is very fragmented
yes it is very unsophisticated yes it is
very uh Hands-On so people have to do
the work so robots aren't going to be
replacing it anytime soon but the big
difference from my perspective is that
the ticket size when you're going to
sell these type of things whether it's
you know fixing somebody's electricity
or whether you're fixing a toilet you
know the average price per per sale is
pretty low and so your ability to really
generate gross profit dollars to cover
your overhead every month and then shoot
out a bunch of ebitda shoot out a bunch
of earnings it's pretty limited because
you have that low order value with
plumbing and with electricians compared
to HVAC for example or even compared to
like homes for example you know if you
sell one home right and you're selling
it for a half million dollars a piece
there's a lot of gross profit dollars to
go around so you have to do I guess what
I'm saying is you have to do a lot of
work to make a lot of money in
electricians and plumbing you can do it
it's just harder yeah and with things
like HVAC like walk us through like a
normal engagement with a customer so you
guys go in like what's an average order
ticket size and then how do you guys
think about uh profit margins and things
like that well it's it depends on the
market like everything else but
generally speaking let's say it's a ten
thousand dollar uh priced unit or an
eight thousand dollar priced unit what
you're trying to do do is you're trying
to go into the home and you're trying to
fix the system that's there and if you
can't fix it you try to give options to
say look you know we can replace this
coil we can replace this condenser we
can do this we can do that and so you
have kind of that service and
replacement component to it the thing
that's kind of interesting from my
perspective is that a lot of these new
units are being able to be more durable
over long periods of time and I think
that's what you know consumers are going
to be pretty happy about in the next 10
to 20 years and I think this is even why
Elon Musk I don't know if you saw he
wants to get into air conditioning
because if he can build something that
lasts for a really long time you could
clean up in the air conditioning space
What are some of the other lessons that
you think people should take away in
terms of investing in these kind of down
markets or building companies right so
obviously when you say things like air
conditioning is oxygen uh that's like a
recession-proof type business I don't
care what the economy is doing uh
there's some places like a phoenix where
in the summer people want air
conditioning they need air conditioning
and they're going to pay for it are
there other things that you're either
looking at or less you've taken from 08
or other Market downturns that you think
well OA was a big deal for me because my
family's stock went from you know the
family business that we founded went
from 46 dollars down to three dollars a
share and so that's a way to Humble
somebody up really quick and so I saw my
dad and my grandfather stressed out
significantly in 08 and I said I never
want to be up at night worried about
putting food on the table for my kids
because you know some cyclical industry
blows up and so while I'm still focused
on housing and I was involved with polti
home significantly where I've made most
of my money has been in these
non-cyclical uh absolutely critical
services and I would encourage people to
do that keep low debt and just cash flow
cash flow cash flow I mean that's what
it's all about a lot of people get tied
up in these different things and the
sexy things and you know fast moving
software and this kind of stuff you got
to make money in my opinion
um or at least I know I got to make
money if I want to give it away on
Twitter and when you are looking at the
growth of these companies how much of it
is growth by acquisition versus like
organic growth where you can go hire
more sales people you can go and get
more business jumped up through you know
various Business Development activities
like do you just try to buy up a bunch
of companies and roll them up or is it
more organic well we buy into the
companies or we buy the companies but
for the most part the growth that's
coming from our know-how having built
you know polti homes in my grandfather's
case and him having transferred a lot of
that knowledge to me a lot of that
institutional knowledge about how to
build these companies I've been able to
then go about implementing it in these
different companies and so our growth
rates are anywhere from 100 to 300
percent and some of these unsexy
businesses like heating and air
conditioning and stuff like that and it
doesn't take a rocket scientist to
figure out if you have a business that's
in air conditioning growing at 100 to
200 to 300 percent per year you can make
a lot of money pretty quickly and
unfortunately or fortunately I need to
do that because I'm giving away so much
money on Twitter yeah how much of the
growth gets Tapped Out in a market like
let's say you're 300 percent you're over
here year and you have for five years
right or whatever the numbers end up
being uh the growth rate naturally will
slow as you get a bigger kind of
denominator but can you just tap out a
market and then you have to make the
decision like either go buy a company in
another Market or like this is the
business that we're going to have
because we just saturated this entire
Market good question first you want to
go to markets where it's very hard to
saturate right so we're in Phoenix for
example we're in Atlanta Georgia we're
in Los Angeles right so
um if we ever get to Market saturation
levels we'll be very happy and we'll be
able to give away a lot of money uh to a
lot of different people
um so yeah that's kind of interesting
but we try to focus on getting the
market right first and not being in the
middle of nowhere where you know the
dollars just don't make sense and we're
trying to make you know a lot of money
doing this as I said so we can
fundamentally transform the way that
philanthropy is done on a direct giving
approach that's what we're trying to do
with Twitter philanthropy what about the
labor market you guys obviously employ a
lot of people
um are you seeing any changes there over
the last year yeah you got to pay people
enough I always hear I love Boomers but
I always hear Boomers say you know these
young people they never want to work but
I always say first of all there's young
people who want to work it's just you
got to pay them enough to want to work
you know and um that's one of the things
we teach in our businesses is people
often say to us well how do you get
people to grow so fast in the trades
right in the heating and air
conditioning and plumbing and
electrician because you know a lot of
people don't want to do that type of
work well some of these guys are making
150 200 300 400 000 a year doing air
conditioning I mean I know one guy who
he was in a different business kind of a
traditional Fortune 500 type role and he
went in and he became an HVAC
salesperson now before you you know say
something about that you know understand
this guy's now making you know seven
eight hundred nine hundred thousand
dollars a year right wow maybe over a
million dollars this year he'll make you
know by the time this year is closed out
so there is just tremendous opportunity
where other people won't want to work
and you know it's not sexy it's not you
know podcasts it's not Mr Beast type
stuff right where you make making money
and I give you guys great credit for
building it it's this on sexy work but
we make good money doing it yeah and
when you talk about like paying people
enough I recently wrote about the
minimum wage and what's fascinating to
me federal minimum wage still 7.25 cents
been that way since 2009. uh obviously
some states have increased the state
minimum wage but what has always been
interesting is that there are private or
publicly traded companies that have set
their corporate minimum wage at much
higher rates so uh you can go to the
list there's you know everything from
Disney to Facebook to Aetna to JPMorgan
Chase to Amazon Etc that all have 15 or
more as their minimum wage that's their
average starting salary or even higher I
think Amazon said like 19 bucks now and
so when you start to look at some of
this stuff the paying them enough you're
essentially highlighting the fact that
politicians at the national level say
7.25 cents is the minimum but companies
are saying I can't get anyone to come
work for seven dollars 25 cents I need
to pay 15 16 17 18 19 an hour just to
get these people to show up well
ironically a lot of that happens to do
with what politicians have caused with
inflation right people need to do that
so in a perverse way they actually
haven't helped as much as they've hurt
by with this inflation and printing all
this money and everything and so you
know people need that type of dollars to
to live this is why you and I get along
is because that's exactly what I was
writing about is that in Turkey they
have 85 I think it's 84 and a half
percent annual inflation so
year-over-year price change of goods and
services in that country is 84 which is
insane nearly impossible for the average
family to survive and buy basic
necessities uh just this week we saw the
Turkish politicians go ahead and vote
and Implement a 55 increase in the
minimum wage and so there's a lot of
people who say hey inflation's High
there's people who are suffering let's
increase the minimum wage but one of the
things that they don't understand is if
you increase minimum wage by 55 you're
essentially increasing the a labor cost
for corporations if you increase labor
costs they're going to increase their
prices to be able to remain profitable
which actually in some weird way means
that they may be contributing to more
inflation rather than actually being
able to just help the people so it's
like a good intended outcome for helping
individual workers but you may actually
be exasperating the inflation Problem by
having the government intervene in the
market and so you know how do you all
think about what's going on in the
economy but also like the decisions you
make and the prices that you choose and
all these things
you're probably not thinking about
inflation as much as you're thinking
about like what are the cost of our
Goods what are the cost of the inputs
what are the cost of Labor like all that
stuff to determine what you're actually
selling this stuff for I think the best
way to do it is to go on a business by
business level so for example we own 12
companies as I said in the air
conditioning space the advice I give to
the guys there is like hey we need to
figure out like number one how should we
be pricing these jobs number two can we
make money doing it because if we can't
make money doing it we can't afford to
pay these people these prices and
ultimately we can't afford to keep the
lights on we can't afford to pay
ourselves you know we got to get paid uh
running these businesses and stuff and
so I literally look at for a living you
know hundreds now thousands uh it's
probably tens of thousands of companies
for a living that's literally what I do
in this kind of space in the Home
Services space and what I'm saying is
that some of these guys shouldn't be in
business and that's not something that
should be you know
um told to everybody but a lot of people
need to look at it in my opinion A lot
of these businesses and say hey can we
actually make a business work now in
those big markets like La Phoenix those
type of markets it can handle a lot of
competition but some of these places
people are competing and they're just
losing their you know what because
they're not priced properly and the
market can't support their businesses
um so it's kind of a sad thing to say a
sad kind of sad thing to see but um you
know if you can't afford to pay people
maybe you need to go to a different
geography or maybe you should be doing
something else uh in business if you had
to go back to the beginning of your
career with all the knowledge you have
and you're a young person today in this
market what would you do
yeah well I'm still screwing up and
learning so that's good
um and so I continue to do that
um but yeah that's just where I've made
most of my mistakes is is through
running these different companies and
you know seeing what pisses people off
and then you know having them quit and
then learning the hard way
um so you know I just say embrace the
mistakes and that's what I've tried to
do but uh you know Finance is the
language of business in my opinion and
that comes from a housing guy a
Tradesman type guy you know who you know
with nails and and you know drywall and
flooring and Roofing and stuff like that
but you can do that stuff all day long
but if you don't understand finance and
I'm talking about literally knowing
income statement balance sheet cash flow
statement I think that's what's going to
make or break people in this next period
of time is people who are really have
what I call in our companies complete
and accurate financials it's just
unbelievable to me how many people are
operating these companies that are doing
10 20 30 50 100 million worth of Revenue
and they don't have complete and
accurate financials what are the biggest
mistakes you see that they make like are
they just like ignorant mistakes or like
lack of focus with the financials yeah
like like when you're looking at a
business and and you see that they're
not complete and accurate financials
like what would you say are like the two
biggest things you see as mistakes well
the most thing is that like so let's say
you're in the podcasting business or
let's say you're in I don't know the
marketing business or let's say you're
even in the housing business okay you
understand those trades very well but I
think what often happens is
entrepreneurs don't want to look and
understand the basic financials so the
balance sheet the income statement the
cash flow statement and from my
perspective when you don't have the when
you don't have the um the understanding
of the trade and the finance at the same
time uh you're really setting yourself
up to get screwed and so from my
perspective that operator I don't care
how great of a mechanic they are how
great of a plumber they are they need to
understand how their financials are
built and closed at the end of every
month and there's a high high
correlation between people who are worth
you know 50 100 200 million dollars and
I'm telling you damn near everyone I've
met knows the trade raid side meaning
the individual specialty as well as the
finance side I've yet to meet somebody
who just knows about the trade side of
things and um yeah that would be
probably the biggest thing what are you
hearing from Banks you talked to a lot
of financial institutions as well
um are they Doling out money to kind of
professional investors and wealthy
people and they're saying hey go in and
start investing now we think now is a
good time to buy up assets that may be
underpriced uh are they still waiting
what are those conversations if you've
proven to make money banks will lend you
money but in this environment right now
everybody's tightening up and if you're
not a proven commodity if you don't have
uh you know if you're not a creditor who
can pay back the money they don't want
anything to do with you from my
perspective and so I think that's also
going to impact private valuations it
already has right but specifically in
The Leverage buyout market and some of
these profitable operating companies I
think you're going to start to see some
multiple compression come down because
financing isn't going to be as available
and that's just a math equation but it's
also I think a lot of these credit
committees at these Banks saying hey you
know yeah we'll give money to polti
because we know he'll pay it back but
you know maybe this person we might not
yeah is that what they say to you
they're like hey you make money we'll
give you money yes basically yeah yeah
people don't like lending money and then
losing money it turns out it's shocking
I mean it happens in these low interest
rate environments where people convince
themselves that they do but that's just
I don't want I don't want you to tell
any of your uh your secrets but uh when
you go to raise money whether it's debt
or Equity do you like I don't raise
Equity thank God okay more so I raised
debt just to you know get a little bit
extra kick on the return when you do
that do you just go back to the same
Partners or do you create like auction
type processes where there's a bidding
war like how do you actually go through
it and uh what I think would be
interesting to people is most people who
listen to this are probably in Tech and
venture capital and more used to the
equity type fundraising but when you're
looking at these debt type deals and
you're going to the banks how exactly
are you able to get kind of best terms
well from a debt perspective what really
matters is cash flow net cash flow how
much money are you putting in the bank
at the end of the day because debt
holders I wouldn't say that they're
smarter than Equity holders but they're
way more conservative and so
um you know again I'm a big fan because
my family has gone from having a housing
business that made a ton of money to
losing billions of dollars a year right
so so we don't want to do that again
that was a big No-No so I try to buy
businesses I don't care whether they're
software whether they're housing that
are making money money and maybe that
limits the growth but you know what I'm
not going to get screwed all the time
and I'm not going to get lines of credit
pulled and those kind of things
so
I forget where were we uh how do you
actually go and raise the the debt
financing so when you go to raise the
money basically you say look okay first
of all I only put things in front of
banks that are bulletproof from a cash
flow perspective because all it takes is
one deal to blow up in my opinion and
then Banks do not view you as a high
fidelity investor anymore now you do
have different private Equity Funds
where they'll have deals blow up and
stuff like that but that also affects
their track record so I really try to
focus on the cash flow make sure it's
recurring make sure it's a stable
business and then and only then will I
go and raise the debt yeah and then how
do you think about paying off the debt
do you just pay whatever the minimum
monthly payments are do you try to pay
it off as fast as possible we have a
phrase that our companies um and it's
not sophisticated but it's one that we
came up with which is Crush debt so so
for example I know exactly what that
means which means it's a great phrase
yeah yeah Crush debt and you know I
talked a lot about net cash flow and
buying these companies with not cash
flow but even more important than buying
companies with net cash flow is crushing
debt because the net cash flow is the
leading indicator to being able to crush
debt and if you start to see your debt
balances go down I'll give you an
example I'll give you a real life
example we just borrowed 10 million
dollars a few weeks ago to do a dividend
recap to take money out of a company
that's doing very well we we decided not
to sell the company because it was just
making so much money it's growing so
fast we poured our heart and soul into
it so we took a 10 million dollar
dividend out of the company
and what we've done is we're not just
focused on the earnings power of the
business but we're actively focused on
paying down that 10 million and I think
we're already paid it down by like two
million dollars or something like that
so so the net debt balance is down to
like from 10 to 8 in a period of however
many weeks and my point being is that to
me is like the ultimate measure of you
know being able to get wealth and
liquidity is being able to get rid of
your debt talk how those work so you've
got a business that business is
profitable it's got cash in the bank you
guys want to take a dividend out why are
you taking on debts because you need to
have some working capital to be able to
operate the business no not at all
entirely the opposite it's we've done
very well we have cash flow we can bar
we can borrow debt but the real reason
we're doing it is because we believe
that U.S dollars are depreciating in
value and so if we go and we buy for
example uh if we go and we buy uh are we
going we borrow debt let's say we borrow
the 10 million and let's say I put the
10 million spy in the S P 500 in my
opinion uh you may be better off
um taking the US dollars putting in the
S P 500 using the cash flow paying a
little bit of interest expense and on a
you know weighted average cost of
capital I think that it's going to make
tons of sense to be investing in the S P
500 than than the US dollar even with
this interest expense so most people are
familiar with the interest rate where
they interact with it is on mortgages
that's probably the number one place and
maybe they've got some treasury exposure
or they've got some uh some interest on
uh on long-standing debt that's a
variable rate or something but for
corporations like you're describing here
what is the difference between the
interest rate that you would have paid
last year kind of during the Mania and
the interest rate that you would pay now
after the FED has uh kind of increased
interest rates so much it's meaningful
but again a good business can afford
increase in interest rates right and I
think that's one of the things that's
very
um
informative about this whole experience
has been and when I try to preach always
is like you know look my family's been
through these cycles and these shitty
businesses excuse my language where you
know boom and bust boom and bust and you
really want to build a business that can
withstand anything and so um yeah that's
what I focus on last thing I want to
talk about is Twitter philanthropy you
are the Pioneer you're the creator of
Twitter philanthropy the first time I
saw you giving away money I was like
holy [ __ ] you know what is it what is he
doing right why is he doing this
um and uh it seems like it's taken on a
life of its own like what is the update
now at the end of 2022 for Twitter
philanthropy I mean it's bigger than
ever it's uh more viral than ever you
know I've always said Twitter
philanthropy will never be successful as
long as it's dependent on me and my
money because I'm just one dude who's
got money
um so we need to get other people
involved in it and that's what we've
done we have this team polti Twitter
account I don't know if you've seen that
but we've got like three or four hundred
thousand followers there between that
and and the polti family Twitter handle
and basically all day every day we're
raising money it's a beautiful thing
we're raising money for people who are
dying of cancer people who need these
type of things so I think The Best Is
Yet To Come yeah and the money just so
people are clear uh when you guys say
you're raising money you're basically
putting a spotlight on certain
opportunities and then people are going
and they're giving the money directly to
these individuals correct it's not like
a traditional uh I'm not touching the
money in the sense as an individual I'm
not going in and then whatever it's
through this team polti which is a 501c3
it's got a board and basically they pop
up these different campaigns and then
what I do is I use my 3.2 million
teammates to help we you know we come
together and we try to help these
individual causes and thankfully it's
gotten so big on these other accounts
that we don't need to use my account all
the time to do that so we use that
really to kind of build out the team and
and compound it so
when you kind of zoom out it's 2022 are
there like two or three lessons that uh
you take away from this year
just don't buy any of the [ __ ] that
doesn't make money
so the Timeless investing principles
just find the things that are throwing
off cash yeah and buy those yeah and and
it's not even that too it's just also
like
there's a lot of stuff that's producing
cash right now it's like okay you know
is that stuff really gonna be around in
five or ten years you know and I'm all
you know I think oil uh is something
that's needed for example but you know
before I invested a ton of money in that
or invested even in some REITs you know
which I know a lot about real estate and
REITs
um is I would just be very careful what
price you're paying what Market you're
in
um because you know I don't think that
it's I don't I don't think the cash flow
is guaranteed even if they're spitting
it out right now yeah it's um it's
always a pleasure to talk to you where
can we send people to find you on
Twitter
No bot Farms no multiple fake identities
don't steal from dead people's
identities start attacking me and my
dead Grandpa you know seriously you know
you're a Twitter detective now like
you're a Twitter uh philanthropist but
you should put in your Twitter bio
Twitter detective if you're gonna start
cracking down on the bot Farms Elon
should hire you to go and find the other
bot Farms we'll see good to see you
thanks for having me all right thanks
thanks so much for coming we'll do it
again